this decision
to come out of the closet yeah the
general thinking at that time is hey
you're doing a show you're dating guys
uh that's sort of the theme of the show
everyone likes ellen dating guys and
this and that and then all of a sudden
you come out and suddenly no one can
accept the fact
that you're dating guys on the show
right they didn't know what to do with
the show because at some point you know
you've gotta date guys you gotta get
married you gotta it was on for five
years yeah and it wasn't even that that
we could have thought of that the
writers didn't have a problem it was me
that came to the writers it was me that
said i i need to do this because i had
this dream
that that kind of made me realize that i
was do you know did i tell you the dream
no no so i have this little tiny bird
this finch this beautiful little finch
and i love it so much and i put it in
this beautiful bamboo one of those
tiered bamboo bird cages and as i put it
in the cage the bird becomes me and i'm
still me and the bird is me in the cage
right and as i put it in i realize that
the bars that are against the window
because i had it against the window to
see fresh air were wide enough for it to
go out and it had been like that all
along but you never would leave bird was
looking at me like wait a minute and i'm
looking at the bird like wait a minute
don't go this is where you belong and
it's a beautiful cage and the bird who
is me says i don't belong here and flies
out so you felt so crushed and i was
like i ca no matter how pretty this cage
is i'm not going to live in it i was i
was doing well financially i was doing
well professionally but i didn't i felt
like i was not
free everything felt like a lie
and and i had so much shame attached to
it too you don't realize how much shame
there is because society makes you feel
like any time you can't say like when
people would say who cares you don't
have you don't have to tell everybody
it's you know
it's nobody's business just and when
people use that as an excuse to not say
when they say my personal life is my no
straight person says that no straight
person says my private life is my own
business you don't even think about it
only only people who are ashamed of or
have to hide something and i thought i'm
not going to carry that shame anymore
that's a that's a really brave thing to
do especially when you're successful to
to come out of the closet especially at
that point in your career very very very
brave thing to do did you talk to people
about the decision yeah and everyone
said no yeah my publicist everyone said
no and what about the people who owned
your tv show they must have been lived
when you announced to the writers i'm
going to be gay on the show yeah well
they were the writers were thrilled they
were like oh my god this is going to be
amazing to write for it's going to be
history-making right and uh and because
i thought well
if i'm going to come out i'm not going
to just come out let's make the
character come out at the same time so
it's this really interesting progression
of the character to realize because
there had been gay characters on
television but there hadn't been a
character that realized that they're gay
late in life and what kind of transition
that would be to all of a sudden tell
everybody and realize it later in life
so i thought it'd be an interesting
thing to write and an interesting thing
to do it at the same time were you
prepared for the [ __ ] storm that went
down once you uh came out i mean did you
think it mattered that much no i thought
is it going to be that much of a shock
that scumbag jerry falwell comes out
starts screaming about ellen degeneret i
mean all hell breaks loose uh you know
your gay friends told you not to do it
everyone said you know i told you so
don't do it did you have a nervous
breakdown at all did you just go berserk
no it at first i just felt like i mean i
was definitely getting attacked but i i
was on such a high of like doing the
right thing for me
that i didn't care but then when the
show got cancelled when i lost
everything
that's when i was like
what am i gonna do so three years
between uh you know all of a sudden your
show is cancelled you feel you feel i
guess like yeah i did the right thing
for me but maybe i made a huge mistake
you don't know do your agenda
another tv show proposed right away for
yeah i tried another show but that was
after three years ago oh right yeah do
your agents start abandoning you do you
get abandoned by yeah i didn't have
agents i didn't have anybody you mean
they wouldn't touch you anymore yeah do
you still do do you ever look towards
those particular people and go [ __ ] you
hahaha do you ever do that no i think
in the beginning of coming back i felt
like that but now i feel complete like
understanding this the business is
business you know and we know that we
know that that we're only as popular as
as the money we make for them and come
on could you if you were in their shoes
could you dump someone who whose career
was all right taking a bit of a dip
right now but but maybe is gonna come
back no but i what i did is i just you
know i started i realized the way i got
to the place that i had been is by stand
up i'm a funny person i write that's
what you did you said i'm gonna go back
you went back out on the right the
beginning is that but is that a defeat
to go back on the road i mean or you
were just kind of like hey that's what i
know how to do i gotta do it yeah it was
scary to do it again but i thought i'm
gonna i'm gonna call it the beginning
because that's how i began and i'm
beginning again right and i am going to
remind people of how i got here